[Music]
on this Monday night the ominous new
warning about where coal bid 19 is
headed the worst is yet to come
as parts of the u.s. reintroduce
restrictions and we have to take it much
more seriously and in Canada were much
better off but new outbreaks are flaring
Alberta's 10 billion dollar plan to
repair the economy promises of new jobs
and new rules on who's allowed to work
and what's behind calls to defund the
police in Toronto they get more money
and the shooting still dora reimagining
what public safety could look like
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
as July approaches and we're all
exhausted by the pandemic there is cause
for both a bit of relief about our
situation in Canada and some trepidation
about other countries the World Health
Organization warns the world is nowhere
close to conquering kovin 19 and the
worst is yet to come the hard reality is
this is not even close to being over the
pandemic is actually speeding up
it is not speeding up in Canada now new
federal modeling shows a steady decline
in infections will take you through that
in just a moment
first though we'll look at the United
States more than 2.6 million people
there have tested positive for Kovan 19
and case numbers are rising sharply by
the day
over the last week dozens of states
recorded a major uptick and the three
states with the biggest populations
California Texas and Florida are hardest
hit in just seven days they've each
recorded more than 40,000 new cases and
in the states that were among the first
to reopen including Florida and Texas
restrictions are now being reimpose
including closing beaches and bars
Jackson prosecco reports Americans have
found no vacation from the virus as
cofee of 19 cases surged out of control
prompting several states to bring back
restrictions we know that if we stay
open we'll have a crowd here
Florida cities are closing beaches ahead
of the fourth of July long weekend bars
are closed and restaurants are back to
limited seating in California and Texas
a fresh rush to slow the spread that
comes too late it's hard not to look at
it and say why did we even why do people
stay at home and then only to go back so
quickly without taking good social
distancing measures case numbers and
hospitalizations are now rising in most
states most rapidly in the south major
cities in Texas and Arizona have nearly
run out of ICU beds deaths which often
lag weeks behind are expected to soar
we're gonna see that number go up over
the course the next 30 days as the case
is in younger
adults new spread to older individuals
it feels like it happened in the blink
of an eye
Danielle Lopez says her uncle Tommy
Macias contracted kovat 19 after
venturing out to a backyard barbecue in
California two weeks ago he later died I
hate to think that he left worrying
about all of us left behind and that he
may have potentially infected somebody
in our family uncontained transmission
remains a major concern with warnings
the u.s. risks losing control of the
pandemic that hasn't stopped some states
from pressing ahead with their phased
reopening plans once the epicenter New
York will begin a limited return to
indoor public spaces next week but
Broadway will stay dark until at least
January should places that have lower
case numbers right now be pressing the
pause button I would think so I would
think they want to see what's happening
in other places and decide that maybe we
should slow down a little bit
heeding that advice New Jersey scrapped
plans to allow a return to indoor dining
this week as America finds itself unable
to bring the virus under control
Jackson Cross Co Global News Washington
the trend lines in Canada are not the
same as the US the new coronavirus is in
steady decline here but that could
change quickly as people begin to travel
and get together especially if the US
canada border reopens after July 21st
prime minister Trudeau said today what's
happening in the u.s. demonstrates the
need for continued vigilance here we
need to continue to be careful even as
we reopen so that we don't lose all the
significant progress we've made through
some very difficult sacrifices by
Canadians over the past months there is
new data tonight showing just how much
progress Canada has made in flattening
the curve updated federal modeling shows
transmission of the virus is largely
under control but with some significant
hotspots as Eric Sorenson reports it
comes with a warning progress could be
lost if Canadians become complacent of
257 new cases reported in Ontario more
than two-thirds are from Windsor Essex
much
of the outbreak there among migrant farm
workers who live in close quarters this
covet is not fair to people Ontario's
premier says the province and Ottawa
have mobilized more testing it's just a
full onslaught down there to nip this in
the bud there it's a sign the novel
coronavirus strikes hardest where people
gather more than 30 active cases have
been identified in a condo building in
Calgary more than two dozen others are
traced now to one nail salon in Kingston
Ontario nationally in the last two weeks
covert 19 cases are mostly concentrated
outbreaks in blue in Alberta and
Saskatchewan and in southwestern Ontario
the Toronto area and the Montreal region
as Canadians have more contact at work
and socially experts say testing should
be based on this new pattern of
outbreaks people who work in grocery
stores and liquor stores we need to be
doing that kind of testing proactively
not because people look sick or thing
they're saying but because they have
occupation or behavior arrests the
national trend remains promising
Canada's outbreak peaked around the end
of April but cases along with deaths and
hospitalizations are all down since then
yet public health officials project
another wave in the weeks ahead and if
so will it be a small one or another
serious wave of kovat 19 we expect to
see some resurgence of cases the key is
to keep the number of cases small
through ongoing core Public Health
practices we must be able to rapidly
detect and isolate cases and quarantine
their contacts meantime Canadian Blood
Services is preparing to do antibody
tests on blood donations to get a more
accurate picture of just how many
Canadians have contracted the virus you
take a whole bunch of random blood
samples and then you test to see how
much kovetz there and that gives you an
idea of how much kovat is out in the
community antibody tests may show
there's been a greater spread of the
virus and possibly greater immunity the
more health officials can track this
disease the better our chance to contain
the next wave Erik Sorensen Global News
Toronto the NHL is reporting a jump in
the number of players infected with
Kovac 19 the league says 26 players have
tested positive since Valen
pterri workouts began on June 8th that
includes 11 players who didn't take part
in team workouts officials are still
pressing ahead with plans to finish the
NHL season despite the pandemic they're
reportedly in the process of selecting
two hub cities where the remainder of
games would be played among the victims
of the coronavirus are the performing
arts and today cirque de soleil whose
shows have been paused for months filed
for creditor protection a Montreal based
circus company which has 900 million
dollars in debt says it's working to
restructure its business as part of the
planned Cirque has agreed to a purchase
deal with an existing group of investors
who would take over liabilities and
invest four hundred and ten million
dollars the deal would keep the
company's headquarters in Montreal and
provide 20 million dollars to support
3,500 employees who were furloughed and
now will be let go permanently a Quebec
Court will hear the case tomorrow and if
the order is granted cert will seek
bankruptcy protection in the u.s. the
Alberta government has announced an
economic stimulus package to help get
it's battered economy back on track that
province has been hit hard by the
pandemic and low oil prices
Heather Eurex West looks at the path
forward and whether the government's
plan will be enough the last few months
have been an opportunity for growth for
Alta ML and Alberta tech company that
develops artificial intelligence
solutions demand is on the rise
companies are spending less money on
expanding production just to generalize
and more money on improving the
operational efficiency within their
existing operations and production Alta
ML is the kind of company the Alberta
government says it's now trying to
attract and retain as it looks to
rebuild an economy that has taken a
beating today we take a big step forward
in that journey with the launch of
Alberta's recovery plan a bold ambitious
long-term strategy to build to diversify
and to create jobs the stimulus includes
10 billion in infrastructure spending
something the province says will create
50,000 jobs and effective July first
Alberta's corporate tax rate will be cut
again dropping from
to 8% I'd say the moves that we saw
today were very much in line with
textbook responses to recessions rather
than old new out-of-the-box ideas
Alberta's plan to create jobs also
includes changes to who can come to the
province to work most temporary foreign
workers will be banned with tens of
thousands of young people and and
restaurant workers out of work we just
cannot justify using having the
government use or the employers use the
TFW programs so it's it's effectively
largely a suspension of the TFW program
Kenny says there will be exceptions
allowed for things like meat packing
plants New Brunswick had to reverse a
ban on temporary foreign workers earlier
this year after industry outcry back at
alte ml the stimulus package is welcome
news in February grants for the tech
industry had been canceled by the United
Conservative Party but with a new eye
towards diversification they're back in
the hopes businesses like these will
stay in the province Heather Eric's West
Global News Calgary calls to defund
police are growing louder depending on
who you talk to defunding can mean
everything from completely dismantling
police forces to shifting funding away
from law enforcement towards community
and mental health resources too many
people especially black and indigenous
people do not feel protected by the
police they feel threatened as might
relay reports it sparked a reimagining
of what Public Safety
looks like the calmness of the latest
Toronto protests belie the seriousness
of the demands to defund abolish or
reimagine the police force we have to
look at alternatives besides just
militarizing the police the protests
have been a constant four weeks
impossible for politicians to ignore the
reality is that these requests have been
coming from our communities for years
and none of us have been active
listeners not the chief not the mayor no
myself
well they're listening now but they
don't like the protesters suggestion of
a 50% cut to the police budget instead
the debate has focused on either a 10%
cut or
the creation of a non police mental
health response team which already
exists but critics say is rarely used
we've had these spikes and shootings or
and everything and every time that
happens they cry out for money more
money they get more money and the
shooting still go up so obviously the
money being allocated for preventing
shootings is not being used properly so
that maybe needs to look be one of the
first places you can look at it's a
debate Ontario's premier says he doesn't
want to step in at least not officially
but I think it's absolutely critical we
keep as many police on the streets
making the calls because when people
Mike when people call 911
they expect the police to be there so
how is public money allocated well in
Canada over 15 billion dollars was spent
on policing in 2018 which is almost four
times as much as the amount of public
money spent on mental health and
addiction care when private spending is
included the amount spent on mental
health care reaches fifteen point eight
billion police responding to mental
health calls is a glaring issue at least
that's what Toronto's police chief says
but he adds if not them then whom a
question even advocates for change admit
needs to be addressed great this is
great energy that people are talking
about it now let's sit down and actually
have a plan and because if you don't
have a plan you you're planning to fail
Micro Lake Global News Toronto in st.
Louis Missouri yesterday a white couple
pointed guns at protesters who were
marching to the mayor's home demanding
police resources be redirected
a couple stood on the doorstep of a
five-story house pointing guns at the
peaceful protesters who were walking
along the private gated street they were
demanding police reform and the
resignation of the mayor on Friday the
mayor read out the names and addresses
of people who wrote letters calling to
defund the police
she's since apologized an investigation
into the confrontation between the
homeowners and the demonstrators is
underway some of Canada's top athletic
wear companies say they'll stop placing
ads on Facebook because the company
hasn't done enough to keep racist false
and dangerous content off its platform
Lululemon Mountain Equipment co-op and
Arc'teryx are joining a growing list of
international brands pulling paid ads
from Facebook until the end of July
organizers of the stop hate for-profit
boycott say hate extremism and
misinformation still thrive on Facebook
and sanctioned misinformation conspiracy
theories and unmoderated hateful groups
ad revenue is Facebook's biggest
moneymaker generating nearly 70 billion
dollars for the company last year a
former police officer accused of a
multitude of crimes in California coming
up the moment the families of victims of
the Golden State Killer have been
waiting for
a big win for supporters of abortion
rights in the u.s. the Supreme Court has
struck down a law that would have closed
nearly every abortion clinic in the
state of Louisiana the law barred
doctors from performing the procedure
unless they had admitting privileges at
a nearby hospital critics said it
amounted to a veiled attempt to restrict
abortion in the five to four ruling
Chief Justice John Roberts broke
conservative ranks and sided with the
four liberal justices he said he went
with the majority to protect past
precedent even though he voted to uphold
a virtually identical line Texas in 2016
it is the first abortion ruling since
President Trump appointed two justices
to the US Supreme Court a former
California police officer dubbed the
Golden State killer has agreed to plead
guilty to 13 murders in a deal that will
spare him the death penalty Joseph de
Angelo also admits to dozens of rapes
crimes that happened too long ago to
prosecute in exchange he'll get
consecutive life sentences with no
chance of parole the 74 year old
terrorized the Sacramento area as a
killer and serial rapists in the 70s and
80s he eluded authorities for decades
and was finally arrested in 2018 after
police used DNA to track him down
through a popular genealogy website
still ahead why hasn't Canada
repatriated citizens detained in Syria
you are watching global national gunmen
stormed Pakistan's Stock Exchange in the
southern city of Karachi killing at
least four people and injuring seven
others part of the assault was captured
on surveillance camera a gunman can be
seen firing into a security checkpoint
before entering the compound two of the
attackers were killed at that checkpoint
two others were shot before they could
get inside the stock exchange building a
separatist group from the southwestern
province of Balochistan claimed
responsibility for the attack there is a
new development in the story of dozens
of Canadians held in Syria over alleged
links to the so-called Islamic state
Human Rights Watch is demanding the
Canadian government urgently bring its
citizens home something other countries
have already done the report says there
are 47 Canadians being held in detention
camps eight of them are men 13 are women
and there are 26 children most of them
under the age of 6 and born in Syria to
Canadian parents the Canadian government
won't confirm any of those numbers none
of the detainees have been charged with
any crime and Human Rights Watch says
they're being held in deplorable
conditions as Abigail Beeman reports the
idea of bringing alleged Isis members
home isn't something that sits well with
everyone I don't think that there is one
person here that's not traumatized
interviewed by Global News in 2019
Kimberley Pullman is one of the
forty-seven Canadians in Syria that
Human Rights Watch is calling to be
repatriated real languishing in these
you know dire and humane conditions with
without being charged with any crimes
meeting criminal charges in Canada is a
lot more comfortable than what they're
doing now so that's their motivation for
coming home they're starving they're
sick the report bring me back to Canada
says the Canadian government may be
unlawfully withholding or limiting
effective consular assistance the
situation in Syria continues to be
extremely dangerous there are countries
that have presence on the ground in
Syria Canada is not one of those
countries they can't provide these
service
is really not consistent with what I've
seen on the ground myself when I
traveled to Syria and what I know of
other countries he have actually
effected repatriation Leah West says
there are ways to help Canadians she
visited two of the camps named in the
report last year she sure conditions are
even worse now and while she says
there's no clear legal obligation for
the government to repatriate the
situation is complex especially those
principles to underlie our international
human rights obligations with this
government really seems to espouse
especially in its most recent bid for a
UN Security Council seat he efforts with
respect to women peace and security
those values I don't think are being
adhered to by the government's refusal
to bring these Canadians home what we
see from the government is is just a
desire not to engage with a challenging
situation and kind of look the other way
they haven't been very effective at
putting a plan in place to actually
prosecute people when they come back
conservatives are opposed to bringing
back Isis fighters but say children are
another story Global Affairs says the
government is particularly concerned
about children and they're reviewing the
report but the ability to provide any
consular help is quote extremely limited
abigail Beeman Global News Ottawa India
is in the grips of the worst locust
outbreak in decades swarms of them are
closing in on the country's capital
they're clouding the skies on the
outskirts of New Delhi not far from the
city's International Airport pilots have
even been warned to take extra
precautions crops are at risk too one
swarm of locusts can devour as much food
as 35,000 people in a single day at
least six states have been affected
locusts are also decimating crops in
parts of the Arabian Peninsula and East
Africa where people are already facing
food insecurity the ultimate balancing
act next Daredevils testing their skills
adventure-seekers near prague were able
to get a thrill with a side of culture
over the weekend a tightrope was set up
between the two towers of Trotsky Castle
which sits high atop two tall rock
formations and high wire walkers were
able to hook into a harness and see how
far they could get anyone who lost their
balance only had a short fall before the
lion caught them and they were able to
get back up and finish their
breathtaking feat no thanks and that is
global national for this Monday I'm
Donna Friesen tonight share Canada is
Devon Alberta where young people
decorated downtown with rainbow colored
ribbons to celebrate Pride Week we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to viewers at global national comm
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye bye
[Music]
you